manuel chasse bonjour vous êtes notre
envoyé spécial au poste frontière de
medica à la frontière polonaise vous
avez pu évidemment parlé à beaucoup de
réfugiés ukrainien quelle est la
situation sur place
et à écouter natacha effectivement vous
l'avez souligné la pologne qui a
accueilli la majeure partie de ces de
ces réfugiés venus d'ukraine plus d'un
million cinq personnes a franchi cette
frontière la frontière entre la pologne
l'ukraine ce que vous pouvez voir juste
ici derrière moi en ce moment c'est un
bus d'évacuation un but d'évacuation mis
en place comme des dizaines d'autres qui
circule toutes les heures plusieurs fois
parra et de jour comme de nuit à la
frontière des bus mis à disposition par
le gouvernement polonais avec ces
réfugiés donc la plupart sont des femmes
ce sont des enfants ce sont des
personnes âgées qui sont venus souvent
avec presque rien avec un sac à dos
souvent un petit sac à dos quelques fois
avec une valise une petite valise à
roulettes quelques fois encore avec
leurs animaux de compagnie ces gens vont
être transportés soit dans d'autres
grandes dans d'autres villes polonaises
souvent ils ont comme but d'aller dans
une plus grande vie comme cracovie comme
varsovie ou bien s'ils n'ont nulle part
où aller ils sont hébergés dans des
centres d'hébergement d'urgence qui ont
été mis à disposition également ces
dernières semaines par le gouvernement
polonais notamment des écoles qui ouvre
spécialement pour cela alors vous le
voyez aussi dernièrement et bien il ya
des tentes qui sont installés là parce
que le nombre de personnes qui arrive
est tellement important et c'est un
nombre qui n'arrêtent pas qui ne
diminuent pas que ces évacuations open à
suivre certaines personnes passent la
nuit ici dans ces tentes sachant que les
températures à cette époque de l'année
sont très basses moins cinq degrés
enregistrés aujourd'hui et des gens qui
n'ont rien vraiment pour se protéger
l'aide humanitaire ici à la frontière
est encore est encore très
très basique donc vraiment une situation
d'urgence humanitaire de crise
humanitaire qui n'a pas l'air de se
résorber alors justement vous parliez de
la logistique et de cette aide
humanitaire qui est encore assez basique
la logistique manque pour accueillir
tout cet afflux de réfugiés manuel
oui c'est pas la volonté qui manquent on
voit des centaines de bénévoles des
centaines des dizaines de ng qui sont
ici il ya même l'organisation
internationale pour les migrations qui
est ici vous le voyez justice il un om
est ici les oem est ici il ya également
une très forte présence des pompiers
polonais des militaires polonais de la
police pour organiser tout cela
simplement le gouvernement polonais
peine à faire face alors il a débloqué
des fonds considérables
ils ont passé le gouvernement polonais a
passé et nos agences débloquant 8 8
milliards pardon de zlotys ça fait
environ 1,6 milliard d'euros ou 1 7
milliard de dollars pour arriver à gérer
cette crise humanitaire qui se passe ici
en pologne alors il ya une solidarité
également du côté de la population de 2
des citoyens polonais il ya énormément
de polonais qui ouvrent leur maison aux
réfugiés la plupart des restaurants ont
des offres spéciales voire offre
gratuitement des repas aux réfugiés et
puis il faut savoir qu'à une très forte
communauté et craignent ici en pologne
et datent d'avant cette invasion russe
avec plus de 2 millions d'ukrainiens qui
vivaient déjà ici en pologne alors ce
qu'on voit également ses qui viennent
ici à la frontière pour récupérer leurs
proches et leurs familles évidemment ils
les prennent également en charge ici
donc c'est vrai que c'est un peu une
source d'optimisme mesuré de la part de
certains polonais qui se disent que
finalement
7,7 ces gens qui viennent d'arriver
cette grande quantité de réfugiés qui
vient d'arriver dans le pays vient
finalement elle va pouvoir quand même
s'intégrer facilement parce qu'il ya
déjà cette communauté ukrainienne
importantes et par exemple les sites
administratifs polonais la plupart sont
déjà traduit en ukrainien en raison de
sept travailleurs qui étaient déjà
présents ici